good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy hump day it is Wednesday
a glorious day a cause of Celebration
here at the morning oh at the toast hope
everyone's having a fabulous day hey Jax
hey enter I'm doing good I woke up today
feeling better than yesterday God bless
hallelujah
hallelujah
isn't that all we could really ask for
you know waking up today better than the
day before it's all we can hope for so
I'm hoping that I've turned a corner on
this sickness I hope I can enjoy the
reels of today's show without watching
them and feeling like I'm about to
sneeze yeah no you were definitely
giving off that nasally Vibe yesterday
but you know what nobody left any mean
comments so that's nice I feel like
unless you're sick it wouldn't trigger
you but for me like I couldn't watch
because it was it was like signaling to
my sickness it's time to sneeze uh
Jackie I'm surprised you haven't made a
comment about how stunning I look yeah
what do you have going on today that
you're all dressed up
I am going to a rare Beauty event where
I think I'm going to be keeping an eye
out for Selena you gotta keep an eye out
for Selena
and I'm pretty sure it's like a small
event like I think I might be able to
get a photo with our girl Selena and
like maybe make a tick tock or something
and so do you think I can ask her like
to say keeping an eye out for Selena do
you think that's like a line she doesn't
[ __ ] with I don't wanna I feel like
Selena has sensitivities to certain
things
and I really wouldn't go there okay like
obviously it like is a Justin thing but
now it's like a cultural thing and I I
know you're right I should just avoid it
I don't want to make her uncomfortable
at her you just never know you don't
know what her relationship is like with
Nicki Minaj right you don't know how she
feels about that name in general like I
just feel like she's has stuff that
bothers her and you don't know what it
is
yeah I know you're right it's best to
avoid but you can like do a tick tock on
your own like behind your back like keep
an eye out for Selena yeah no I'm just
gonna I'm definitely gonna do it on my
own but I don't wanna trigger her you're
totally right so you're just gonna go
there is it a lunch is it a like a show
no idea thankfully counselor it's like
very small so there were like no plus
ones and I was like damn and then I
heard counselor was also invited I was
like thank God
and I just feel like it's actually not
fair to the other girlies who have to
show up alone knowing like I have my
sister like it's actually not fair I
know but some of those other girls like
have influencer friends who will be
there and like you don't so
um
you have influencer friends but they're
not they're not the rare Beauty types
I wouldn't say I think I think I'll
actually you know I'm actually kind of
nervous like I don't love influencer
events I don't go to them often but like
this one is obviously premium and I
didn't have anything else going on today
so I'm gonna go and I'll definitely feel
old even though me and Selena are the
same age so we're just like you know
you're younger than her
oh not me not being the oldest person in
the room thank God yeah I think Selena's
my age
yeah no Selena's definitely like a year
or two older than me she's in the 92
crew
oh it's a good crew Miley Nick Jonas
so true
92 for life so that's why I look
stunning and why I'm repeating an outfit
I wore this weekend it's like if it
works it
it works you know it's really cute I
might actually get it and copy you you
know who it is someone we've actually
had on this podcast Norma Kamali I
literally like actually thought about
this yesterday and hadn't thought about
it in so long like that was such a cool
guest that we had I know and like we
weren't lying she knows how to draw like
how to dress a woman she's looking for
some new clothes that are so versatile
that look nice but are also comfortable
like they're perfect work clothes there
day to night clothes they're obviously
meeting Selena outfits check out Norma
Kamali no and you're right she like
definitely knows how to like fit
clothing on like a real body like I
appreciate that I I've worn her stuff
many times at different sizes yeah me
too I wore her stuff when I was pregnant
she has like that one dress she has two
dresses that are similar one is one
sleeved one is long sleeve and it's
great for a bridesmaid it's also great
for a pregnant bridesmaid I have the
long sleeve one she just has great stuff
and we had her on the podcast and that's
like
why we're not like other podcasts not at
all and Lop
n lap tour we should go on an nlap tour
we by the way don't tease the people
because you know I'll do it it's all
about you
I know but I feel like would you rather
go on a solo tour or podcast tour
well
the only benefit of going on a solo tour
is I don't have to split the money with
you right but you don't know like how
harrowing it is to like be on stage by
yourself and just be doing everything by
yourself I think like if we went on a
podcast tour like you and I first of all
it would be so fun it would be genuine
fun yeah and I wouldn't have like the
pit of like oh my God because us podcast
that's in my bones like I wouldn't even
have to prepare I would just get up
there and just like make some [ __ ] up
you know yeah but we do here every day
it would right it would be so fun we'd
have to make Counselor come she would
open for us
she would open for us and what would she
do I think she would give them all a
Stern talking to it would be like q a
like advice and she would just yell at
you the whole time and you'd live in
tears but you'd be better off for it
you'd be glad to have had that time with
counselor and sometimes like the
counselor is going to tell you the
things you need to hear that nobody else
in your life is going to tell you that's
what counselors do
let me tell you how today's episode is
going to be so crazy you guys today it's
not April Fool's it's not opposite day
but the toast is topsy-turvy today yeah
and
you're just not ready for it so Jackie
and I have decided we're gonna try it
out for today I think we're gonna like
it but if we don't we'll go back to the
way that it is we're gonna switch it up
you know I'm always doing the ads
reading dear toasters I'm burning
yourselves Etc and Jackie reads the
stories
um and Jackie I feel like you're like
gotten fatigued with reading the stories
and I've definitely gotten fatigued with
reading the ads no it's not so much that
I've gotten fatigued reading the story
so we just get so many complaints like
these stories stink and I feel like I
always ask you if you want stories that
you want to contribute but maybe like we
just need a fresh perspective like you
choose the stories and I know that you
get fatigued reading the ads and like
the few times I've had to do them in
your stead like I have the greatest time
the best time I think it's so fun so we
were like I feel like that will bring a
freshness to the show if you're choosing
the stories and like
you know a new broom sweeps clean right
I'm doing the ads and reading gear
toasters I didn't realize it was
Wednesday so I have a lot of reading to
do but that's fine so it's a big day
Wednesday we're obviously going to do
deer toasters at the end of the episode
I have stories
um also I chose a story about The Real
Housewives of Miami so we can talk a
little bit all caught up oh I'm not so
much all caught up and I have thought
just really one thought that sums up the
season and our story is about Lisa so I
feel like that's the thought you
probably have right sort of it's just
about the season how actually I love the
real houses in Miami and I'm sure the
season will be good on the back of
Lisa's divorce but it's not a good
season so far like I'm bored tears well
we will get your hot takes in our I
think it's our third story about Lisa
Hawk Stephen and also like stepping out
with a man of Lisa and Larsa beefing
like Cuts me to my core okay then you're
gonna love the story okay
I'm trusting and I'm believing and I'm
all caught up so we also have some very
sad news I'm sure everybody saw this
morning
so we'll talk about that and you guys
just let us know like how do you how do
you like the opposite day Vibes because
I'm not looking for a permanent switch
up but maybe till the end of the year
maybe it's like a once a week thing just
like a fun way to keep the show fresh
that's a thing like we're fresh and
we're always looking for ways to become
fresher I'm constantly seeking out
freshness in my everyday life
brush yourself
refresh yourself
foreign
anyways we could Jump Right In even
though a thing about YouTube stories is
like you like to like give all the
stories away before we start I see and I
already know two out of five already oh
well okay I see you might call it giving
away but what I would call it is just
you know getting everyone's what do you
call it like dipping your toe in the
water that's even a taste a taste you
know so you know it's not like a big
surprise what's coming but maybe you're
right I did just kind of spoil the whole
episode should we just start over Okay
no no no but also it's so weird for me
to go into an episode like totally blind
I don't know what we're talking about I
know I feel unprepared I feel like I
didn't do my homework is how I feel but
that's what I do you have to read the
stories and explain it to me no and now
I'm putting myself in an extremely
vulnerable position after five years of
you reading the stories and me endlessly
mocking your pronunciation I have to be
perfect and the beauty of reading the
ads is no one can mock your
pronunciation for reading because like
we have to be serious we're doing our
job we're doing an ad yeah no so I'm
definitely gonna be
um spending my nights like doing
enunciation classes and like what's it
called the diction dialect yeah diction
classes because I will not give you the
opportunity to mock me yeah well I'm
really excited to see what you have
cooked up for us today yeah take on the
stories it wasn't you know a bounty but
it wasn't like a desert day there wasn't
so many stories to choose from but there
also wasn't you know nothing okay I have
no idea what it's gonna be
it's kind of crazy kind of crazy so I
guess we should jump in so you can head
over to Selena's we are the that Tick
Tock sound crazy crazy girls that's
literally us today what we're doing
today is so wild
don't call the police don't go don't
call the police I know we're being crazy
but it's okay it's okay it's end of the
year like crazy things happen like this
is our holiday party you know we're
drunk in the workplace I'm drinking
liquid death I'm literally drunk we did
say that this final week of episodes
before the end of the year like is gonna
be our most unhinged yet and you know
what sorry we keep our promises
sorry you hate to see it
you hate to see girls living up to their
word
you really do
all right well
I'm nervous but are you ready I'm ready
without further uh
where are you Theo loves his auntie here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know
thank you so much mclartia but I have to
let you know before we jump into the
stories that today's episode is brought
to you by Noom so listeners pay
attention because I'm sure so many of
you are already thinking about your New
Year's resolutions thinking about how
you want to start fresh just like this
show fresh to death and some of you
overachievers might be wanting to start
early and that's where noon comes in
whether you want to start now or you
want to start on Jan first you need to
know about Noom because Noom is the best
we've been talking about noon on the
show for years it is an app that helps
you manage weight loss set goals achieve
goals get help get resources and it is
wonderful so new weight uses psychology
that's why they say losing weight starts
with your brain the program helps you
understand the science behind your
eating choices and why you have cravings
they also have a huge food database so
that you can input all the things that
you're eating in a day and you can see
your day at a glance see things that you
might want to change things you didn't
realize maybe weren't the best for you
it's really all about learning it's
about information it's about data and
it's about you and we're going to help
you get the results that you need so I
love new whenever I'm on my [ __ ] I'm
using new I'm leaning on it it's a
friend it's a crutch it's a resource and
it's getting me the results that I want
to see and it's helping me learn along
the way I feel like one of the hardest
parts about starting a new lifestyle a
new diet achieving a goal is not having
the information and not knowing what to
do and Noom is that that Trend that
resource and it's going to get you the
goals that you want so stay focused on
what's important to you with new weight
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noon.com toast
that's
n-o-o-m.com toast to sign up for your
trial today
so check out noom's first ever book also
the new mindset a deep dive into the
psychology of behavior change available
for pre-order wherever books are sold
you know we love a good book here at the
toast and who knew that Noom was
following the steps of McLarty on
writing a book
really not them copying my brand
no but we're sisters we're sisters
because we are sisters we stand together
today's also brought to you by diff
eyewear we loved if I were here because
you know what when we got our Shades
done we cannot see the haters and dude
we're blocking out the haters stiff is
making it so easy to block out the
haters we love this new sponsor they'll
make you look like a celebrity for a day
or every day if you want to wear them
every day and they're giving away a
thousand dollars Cash Plus sunglasses
for a year to kick off the holidays so I
personally just got a bounty of if I
wear sunglasses I'm keeping them in the
car I was been wearing them for my
driving lessons they're keeping the Sun
out of my eye and also sometimes you
forget to bring a pair of Shades and
like honestly it's probably distracting
because it looks like there's a celeb
out on the road yeah either causing
drama on the road I don't want that kind
of attention but like with my diff I
wear sunnies I just look like a star I'm
actually wearing a pair of my deaf
sunnies today to my Selena event because
like I'm gonna be with another celebrity
so I figured I should look like one too
celebs stealing celeb things right like
they have the cocoa Shades which were
actually designed by Khloe Kardashian
they have a line with Lauren Lane Our
Queen they have Edge cat eyes Chic
oversized Shades every frame is so
sophisticated and they've just released
a brand new style with Jesse James
Decker hers are classy and versatile and
designed to flatter every Fox we love
that celebrate a season with a season of
style with diff eyewear run don't walk
run to diffeyware.com toast for a chance
to win one thousand dollars cash and dip
sunnies for a year you guys diff sunnies
if you're going on vacation if you just
you know like to walk down the street
looking fabulous
diffeyware.com toast
all right my turn now very well done
Jackie truly a work of art thank you so
much I feel like you could feel the
passion that I have for these Brands a
hundred percent I was like kind of like
receiving that energy from you I saw you
on your phone I feel like you were
downloading new
uh I actually was I was also shopping on
dips to get myself some new sunglasses
that's my effect
um okay so our first story is really
really sad I feel like the news broke
like 20 minutes ago and everyone is
talking about it because it's so
shocking DJ Steven twitch boss Ellen's
DJ is dead at 40 by Suicide so Stephen
also known as twitch boss the fame DJ on
the Ellen DeGeneres talk show is dead
and TMZ has learned it appears to be a
suicide law enforcement sources tell us
that Steven's wife Allison holker ran
into an LAPD station on Tuesday and she
was frantic because she said Stephen had
left home without his car which is
something that was not like him at all
we're told a short time later police got
a call to a shooting at an LA hotel and
they found Steven there dead from an
apparent self-inflicted gunshot wound
Hulker tells people that Steven lit up
every room he stepped into he valued
family he valued friends and Community
Above All Else he was leading with love
and light and that was everything to him
he was the backbone of our family the
best husband and father and an
inspiration to his fans she continues
Stephen we love you we miss you and I
will always Save the Last Dance For You
everyone knows Stephen he was DJing on
The Ellen Show since 2014 up until her
show ending in 2020 he got his big break
in Showbiz on So You Think You Can Dance
he came as runner-up and him and his
wife hosted several reality shows
together they got married in 2013 they
had just celebrated their nine-year
anniversary on Saturday they had three
kids and Stephen was 40 years old rest
in peace
oh my God I have like chills this is
like the saddest story yeah especially
because I know you don't like keep up
with Tick Tock but he had like
honestly I think he was bigger on Tick
Tock than he was in his TV career with
Ellen like he him and his wife I think
he has like five million followers his
wife is 2 million they have like a
family account they're always making
content she dances too so it's like
dancing content with hit with his wife
with his kids like this this really cute
like honestly picture-perfect life and
it's just this is such a testament to
one
Nothing Is What It Seems on social media
and it's so important to remember that
and two like the very real Mental Health
crisis going on in the country and
honestly it reminds me of what you were
saying when we were talking about
Salinas documentary I just feel like for
so long now we've been talking about
mental health and we're just talking
about it I don't feel like in any real
way we're making like a a positive
impact or like really providing like
helpful resources I just feel like every
even at the bottom of this TMZ article
it's like if you were someone you know
is struggling it all feels like very
surface yeah I feel like there's not a
lot of tangible
things that we know how to do to help
people aside from like talking about it
but like how do we improve the situation
I don't I've not seen it being improved
like in the country this makes me this
is heartbreaking like I know
three kids
I I I I don't have the words no it's
really upsetting and I feel like so many
people
um
we're such big fans if it's like I feel
like he has like a real Community that's
being impacted by this and like
obviously so many people I feel like
know him from Ellen but so many people
like love him from his social like him
and his wife really shared a lot of like
their life in their house and their kids
and I think social media is such a a
contributor to negative mental health
and I just feel really sad by this and I
feel like everyone is so shocked
because like his whole brand is positive
let's just get up and dance like get out
get healthy get exercise go get out
there and
you just really never know what
someone's going through yeah I just I
hope that like I feel like if someone's
in this position not in the person who's
going through it but like the people
around them their family their wives
like I I wish that there was
we knew what we could do to help people
you know and also like what is causing
so much of this pain that people are
suffering from because it's more than
ever so there must be some sort of
catalyst and maybe it is social media
and the bigger you are on social media
even though it can be such a positive in
your life and give you job opportunities
and all of the you know ways to connect
with people like if it's such a negative
influence and there's something that
should be done because like this is
horrible no when I actually was just
watching the 60 Minute segment about
Tick Tock and it said they like surveyed
like uh
young people in this country and ask
them what they want to be when they grow
up and the most popular answer was a
social media influencer
our priorities are out of back well the
the um
the the 60-minute segment I was watching
was all about um Tick Tock and how like
you you're always saying this how like
in China right now they took a survey
what a young kids want to be and they
wanted and the most popular answer was
like an astronaut
because Tick Tock in China is like very
educational yeah and you're you're
limited into how much time you can spend
on it it was a good segment it was like
um where did I see it oh on Instagram
mosha
no literally not me literally being the
problem yeah no but I mean I guess
that's you do get good information and
good things out of Tick Tock but I think
it's like the bigger picture of how much
time is being spent on it how much
you're invested in other people's lives
not you but one especially
impressionable like you are your own
person I try all the time it's hard to
move you into doing or feeling yeah no
other way in the way that you feel your
stubbornness might help you in the
battle against Tick Tock no but I also
do think about how like yeah I always
joke like that we're old and stuff but I
feel so grateful that we didn't start
getting like really active on social
media until like late in high school
when like you're
not fully formed but you're much less
impressionable than like a middle
schooler you know also now kids in the
fifth grade are on Snapchat yes but also
really active on social media was so
different in high school yes than it is
now for us that meant we came home from
school and we logged on to Facebook like
for the kids now it means in school all
day every day they're battling against
this addiction to their phone and it's
right there in their pocket like I
remember when we were in high school
like I used to spend a lot of time on
Facebook and I would be like oh I feel
like I spend like a lot of time on
Facebook I should go like practice the
piano or something like this can't be
good no but also the time we were
spending on Facebook was like engaging
with people we actually knew yes nobody
was putting up like filtered photos we
were putting up like Blurry mobile
uploads like it I I don't think the
level of toxicity was even comparable to
what it is now like there wasn't this
like Beauty standard it was really just
a way of keeping in touch with like your
friends from Camp yes there were it was
much less harmless but I do think this
idea of being invested in your online
self and how the world sees you is
veering towards where we are now but I
think one of the biggest things is we
were talking to and engaging with and
looking at people who we no not this
idea of people who we have no idea who
they are what they're going through like
you just see what they want you to see
yeah by the way this conversation is
like separate to the to what's going on
with twitch I don't think necessarily
that's even what happened no no I think
when we're talking about like the Mental
Health crisis like you can't ignore like
social media's impact on that and this
is so sad yeah
like I just feel a real sadness for his
wife and his kids
I might be beyond beyond and it's
because like their family's so cute I'm
sure I'm sure everyone like I hope
people rally around them and they have
the support that they need but this is
devastating yeah
um so that was our first story sorry you
know it's
sad but that's the reality of what's
going on our second story is
another story that I spoiled already but
Lisa hochstein was seen canoodling with
tech entrepreneur Jody Glidden so I'm
not going to read the article is that a
man or a woman
oh sorry Jody is a man
um so Larsa was on watch Robin's live
would have been great if it was a woman
too I just wanted of course we just need
to Clarity
um
Larson was on Watch What Happens Live
and Lisa came with her they had like
this girl's night out in New York so
they're back on good terms so there's no
need for you to fret thankfully but like
why can't I watch the terms I feel like
I'm always looking at them on social
media and they're always together in the
clubs even before Lenny went away like
they were always friends on Instagram
and now I'm watching them on TV and
they're beefing that's not that doesn't
work for me no that's so fair
um So Lisa came to support and then they
had like a gno where they went out to
catch steak after Watch What Happens
Live Lisa they obviously called the
paparazzi on themselves but because this
article is like every single detail Lisa
was spotted out walking out not holding
hands but just standing next to this guy
Jody Glidden
um and then Larsa was there so it was
like kind of a double date Larsa was
there with you know who she's been
claiming has been her good friend but
they're holding hands it's Marcus Jordan
who's Michael Jordan's 31 year old son
Larsa is 48 so there's a a large yeah
but his you know his Gap there his
frontal lobe is developed
um she Larson maintains that her and
Marcus are still friends or just friends
and the same with Lisa Lisa's like I'm
not in a serious relationship it's only
been seven months since the separation
but I'm just like having fun and this
guy's like a tech entrepreneur let me
get he's the CEO of uh intro Hive which
is a software company
and what does he look like
Lisa is 40. he's very cute like very
normal looking like I couldn't describe
you is he older or younger than her
it doesn't have his age so Lisa's 40.
and he is
unknown okay well I love this for her I
was watching last night
and the last scene of the most recent
episode was truly heartbreaking like
they have Lenny's hot mic trying to
spoil it for me because I do want to I
know sales are ready because they're
getting divorced and he has a girlfriend
yeah but it's Lenny's hot mic he's
talking to his friend about how he's
going to be single soon over like Lisa
in the backyard they're hosting a party
and like Lisa just like taking pictures
with her friends like truly [ __ ]
oblivious like talking to everyone
earlier about how they're her and
Lenny's relationship has highs and lows
and right now they're in the high like
she is God has no [ __ ] clue I think
she knows that her relationship is
strained but it's been strained I think
for a lot of their marriage and they
work through it and then their highs and
losing right now I think Lenny's being
nice to her because like he's so happy
in his personal life like with his
girlfriend but he said
his friend asked are you still sleeping
with Lisa and he was like no because
then I'd be cheating on the person that
I really care about
oh [ __ ] yeah my stomach sank and it's so
crazy because like last week Lisa's
going on like about her marriage on the
show like how you know we're doing good
we had dinner together whatever and next
week like they're in the keys and and
he's trying to bring the girlfriend
around the house and like in the in a
matter of two weeks like her life just
completely unravels and
as much as she says like she does her
family's finances and she's in charge of
the house like
she is a kept woman yes okay and proudly
I am so this is one of the relationships
where it's like if it were to dissolve
like she's someone I would really worry
about because I don't I think she's a
strong person every time she gets into a
fight I'm always surprised by how much
she can see on her ground but like I
Lenny isn't is responsible for their
entire life yeah do they mention a
prenup or anything I haven't heard it I
don't know I feel like they do have a
prenup okay if they don't then obviously
we have nothing to worry about but the
fact that when I saw this article I
can't lie I like breathe I'm like good
like she just needs to date another rich
man because she was a kept woman if they
had a prenup she obviously is going to
get child support and her kids are
really young but like she lives this
extravagant lifestyle she does have a
career as a housewife as an influencer I
feel like when you're so rich
and you become like a famous reality
star at slash you know you get a huge
amount of Instagram followers you don't
really like capitalize on it like you
don't need it but now I think we're
gonna see her you know slumming it with
the best of them yeah I think that
she'll be able to have a career and be
fine but like not nearly at the level
that she has been living she lives in an
80 million dollar house her closet maybe
has 40 Birkins like every outfit has a
different brick and then like no amount
of Instagram influencing is can get you
that gonna get you that unless you start
your own business and have a lot of
success but
anyways I'm just happy then I was
thinking like why can't Lisa have a
boyfriend like after Lenny breaks her
heart and goes up with his girlfriend
like Lisa should fall in love Lisa
should have a boyfriend who loves
certain cares about her and like I don't
know if it's this Tech guy but I I hope
Lenny saw those pictures this morning
like and he gets a little bit a taste of
his own medicine yeah no like of course
you don't have to stay married to anyone
but he's going about this in like the
meanest way like I heard he cut her off
um if they have to clean up like in the
show they have footage from like they
teased it a little bit where it's like
he's trying to get her out of the house
and he was like unless I go through the
courts you will not leave the house but
like that's the mother of your children
and where is she supposed to go and is
she taking her kids with you until
you're gonna stay alone in the 10
bedroom house when the kids are going to
go live in like a condo right like a
normal situation like this I feel like
even with like someone who's really
spiteful like Lenny is like you're so
happy go with your other girl leave your
yes for now leave the mother of your
children and your children in the house
that they live in and you can go you
know
gallivant around town with your new
girlfriend yeah I
I don't know why he has to be so
spiteful towards her when he's so happy
and like if he just like
you know gets divorced in a normal way
and is like kind to her like he'll get
what he wants even sooner which is to be
separated I also feel like this is going
to negatively affect his business
because I think a lot of women and
that's who he works on is women are
going to take Lisa's side and be like
you know and his boobs aren't that much
better than anyone else's where it's
like I don't want to go to this guy
who's like ethically compromised for
sure but I have to believe that like
foreign
he's a plastic surgeon but even like the
great to live in an 80 million dollar
house I think there are other elements
to his business it's possible like I
don't know I'm just making this up but
like you know he owns a patent on some
sort of like silicone like I don't think
clients are what bought the 80 million
dollar house like I think he's a really
smart doctor he probably made some good
Investments I think maybe he owns a
patent like I just I I can't understand
how even you haven't got any tits you
have to do I know but I think he does
that many tips like look at Terry Dubrow
Paul's money was also Adrian's money
Paul's one new too I think Terry Dubrow
also I think like when you get to that
level of plastic surgeon
you have your hand in a lot of different
things and like you're the best at what
you do so you create like inventions and
[ __ ] like that's how I think it honestly
if anybody knows I'm actually really I
might be wrong but I think like
the majority of Terry dubrow's money and
the majority of Lenny hochstein's money
that come from other stuff in the
medical space not just the act of
putting on new tits and noses okay
that's what I think
both do boobs it might like if they're
doing boobs that are like what I have no
idea what a boob job costs but yeah I
mean Terry also like they are very
successful in their TV like they were on
botched for like 10 years yeah but they
had the house before botched yeah yeah
yeah no I'm just curious you're right
like he has like a skincare QVC but that
ain't it yeah I just hope that he's not
terrible towards her because
that's just so painful it's already been
painful enough like she had no idea they
were getting divorced and he has a
girlfriend he has a whole other life and
like and he acted like such a [ __ ] with
his mic on obviously he didn't know that
he was being no he knew that he was Mike
his friend was like are you wearing
Mikey he's like that's why I'm
whispering like dumb
dumb yeah dumb
and there's another scene where he's
like yelling at her when he's saying
like I know you're not gonna leave this
house without the courts and he looks
over and sees the camera right okay then
there was the scene I don't know if you
saw this where the nanny fell in the
shower
oh God no okay then what they were
having a romantic dinner outside and
someone comes running out their Nanny
fell while she was taking a shower and
she broke her arm or her wrist and she
needs to go to the hospital and so
they're they're like Lisa's freaking out
and it's like okay I'm gonna call an
ambulance and Lenny was uh
measured but then became like Stern and
he was like you don't call an ambulance
for this either call an Uber or have
someone drive her it's an abuse of the
system like this isn't an act she
doesn't need an amateur she broke her
wrist we need to ice it and we need to
get her to the hospital and Lisa like
asked the chef she's like would you call
an ambulance he was like yeah and so
she's like I'm gonna call him and then
he like comes in and yells at her and
it's like don't do do you understand me
do not call him like he was speaking so
nicely to her but like I'm not sure that
his point was wrong no by the way uh
even I know that like that's not what
you call an ambulance for an ambulance
is when you like you can't afford to
drive because that time is so precious
right and also like an ambulance will
give you treatment in the van and you
need that time of treatment whereas like
if you have to have your wrist set or
arm surgery like they're not doing that
in an ambulance anyway right an
ambulance is like bringing the hospital
to you yeah temporarily so I don't think
he was wrong and at first I was like of
course we're calling an ambulance like
she fell and then it was like oh maybe
that is an abusive system okay but the
way he spoke to her was so uncomfortable
now there were so many other people in
the house and everyone was uncomfortable
yeah
damn that's rough like no I'm I I had to
finish my book for book club last night
which I did in my book clubs tonight and
I actually did not like flicker in the
dark which is shocking because everyone
was first of all I knew from the second
the book started spoiler alert who the
actual killer was how
oh my God it was so obvious I did not
think so the second she said her dad
turned around and looked at them and
said be good
mm-hmm
duh no I had no idea like the spoiler
like the heart her fiance thing threw me
through a loop but I don't know I'm just
very uh and I'm not even good at
guessing stuff I'm actually like dumb as
[ __ ] like people are always like you
couldn't like honestly when when the end
of Shutter Island I was like what who
would have ever guessed that yeah and
you know what I mean but like I've never
guessed something like I'm not smart
like that and even I was like damn this
is dumb
um and my God if I had a knife I would
have stabbed the protagonist she was
being so dumb like the thing is and on
each of this everyone who's ever been a
movie or a book main character when you
find something out about a crime go to
the police
then you won't get framed okay okay
it was it was whatever but so I only got
to watch like an episode and a half and
actually I agreed with what you were
saying but I thought it would change
like this whole thing of Lars is saying
I saw this Instagram account where they
said hookers live in this and then Kiki
ran and Marisol ran and told Larsa so
dumb I'm like this is we're so Above
This Miami is really I think when they
found out they were going to be on
peacock they thought it was like but I
actually think it's the best thing for
them like they're really in their only
gets edited so differently it looks more
like selling Sunset like it's very
streamer it's very elevated and I think
they're better than the storyline yeah
the storyline was written also Kiki such
a snitch you could tell that Lisa felt
really bad about it and that she was
gonna go to Larson she said it and she
was gonna go to Larson just like admit
it and I think that Kiki could have been
a good friend by not saying anything at
first and then if Lisa never admitted it
Kiki could tell her but like give her a
chance to just explain herself like she
didn't say it maliciously she was just
like being gossipy and drunk and like
it's really not a big deal no Kiki is a
friend of and I think she's really
buying for that full-time position and
that's what that move was and they all
left out the contact she was quoting an
Instagram account and yes she misquoted
but they just said Elisa said this
building is full of only fans and
hookers no but still even to like quote
an Instagram account that would talk
[ __ ] about like where you live is
is rude it's not no for sure but like
it's but it's leaving that out is
intentionally misleading it was it
requires context yeah but it's not a
capital offense it shouldn't be
something that's so friendship ending
but I had to fast forward through a lot
of people's scenes and I wasn't even
like trying to go quickly but I I
physically could not watch Julia's
scenes Julian Adrian together is
Dreadful Dreadful honestly I I can't her
talking about like being I don't even
know what she's talking about because I
had to fast forward but I think her
storyline is that she's like bored in
her life because her girls went away and
like Martinez just like not
happy with her I want to know about more
about Martino like Martinez by the way
I couldn't agree more the most
interesting thing about Julia is her
wife right I don't care about the farm I
don't care about her friendship with
Adriana I don't care what her thoughts
are on her relationships with the women
but when they went behind the scenes at
the Miami open and Martina like I
thought that was so interesting I think
Martinez actually really smart and like
I think she has like this no [ __ ]
attitude and her wife is like so full of
[ __ ] that I actually think it's like
straining their marriage yeah I totally
agree but Martinez everything yeah she
is everything I I appreciate her on the
show but like she should be the why
can't she be the housewife I feel like
the network approached Martina and
Martina was like no but my wife will do
it because like she's more like that and
she thought it would be like good for
her wife to like have this thing yeah
because Julie like needs things right
now she's like right a kind of a bored
housewife and yeah you have the show and
you have your farm like what more are
you looking for she's trying to get back
into modeling now she's positively
Dreadful that looks forward
I also have to fast forward through
Nicole's family scenes
you know how I feel about Nicole I don't
mind her in the group setting at all I
couldn't care less about her family her
her parents and stuff like her kid and
their house is like that that our house
the cars and the chefs and the boats and
the planes uh 100 but when she's like
beefing with her parents like Fast
Forward no like we really don't care
yeah so I'm just so steadfast in my
obsession with Marisol and Alexia like I
just love their friendship Marisol is
like the best style everything she wears
is like designer and so cute yep like
when she went to get her nails done at
Frankie Alexia and Frankie's and she was
wearing that Prada like um dress that's
like kind of like overall straps and
those Chanel like Teva like shoes she
looks so cute yeah how does she have all
this clothing
I don't know but she has amazing style a
couple of the girls have really great
style and I actually would say Marisol
maybe has the best style but they all
always look wonderful and that's a
that's a treat yeah a lot of them look
sometimes like a little gaudy like so
like very direct chemc like so many
baby I know I feel like Marisol does it
like a really tasteful elegant mature
way yeah
I mean Marisol is also definitely an
alcoholic yeah functioning but she also
said she's never gets hungover so it's
like if I never got hungover yeah I
drink all the time but it's so true your
hangovers make you stop drinking because
it's not worth it right or maybe she's
never hung over because she's never not
drunk no but like it would it would it
would hit you after someone she said
she's never had a hangover yeah no I
drink the same too if life would be so
much fun
so true all the pros
so I was happy to see Lisa out with like
an eligible rich man because that is
what she needs yes it is what she needs
I'm so happy to see that I think the
rest of the season is going to be
heartbreaking and if it wasn't for this
divorce like there is no season honestly
agreed
so before we get into our next story
I've just gotta let you know that
today's episode is brought to you by
Bruce
Bruno's outside the door like Mommy
what's going on and I said Bruno I have
to tell you about Bruce because it's an
electric toothbrush that will change the
way you think about brushing your teeth
with powerful Sonic technology and Ultra
Gentle bristles the Bruce redefines what
it means to have super clean teeth it's
like that feeling when you just leave a
dentist a fresh whole mouth clean every
single day so Bruce is amazing on so
many levels let me tell you first the
teeth brushing aspect which is the most
important aspect it's huge they go in
there they get all of those gummy things
and things that get trapped and just
nasty teeth things urush gets him out
every time I go to the dentist they're
like what toothbrush shoes and I'm like
ma'am I use a brush and it's wonderful
and she said yeah because you haven't
been here in two years [ __ ] but your
teeth look okay I'm like thank you so
much it's the brush I'll give you a code
when I leave
you can tell the rest of the patients
anyways not only does Bruce get your
teeth in check cleans them fabulously
they have a bunch of different modes
they even have a tongue mode you should
check out because you got to clean your
tongue too don't forget about the tongue
it also looks beautiful on your bathroom
counter some of these other electric
toothbrushes look like a spaceship
that's about to Jet off to Mars Bruce is
just this elegant little thing comes in
fun seasonal colors I'm personally
rocking the mauve and I love it
so get 20 off when you pick your brush
brush kit and plan when you go to
brush.com toast that's 20 off when you
go to brush.com toast the brush kit
includes Bruce electric toothbrush three
brush heads magnetic charging station
and a Sleek travel case if I had to sum
up Bruce in one word I would say Sleek
because that's what it is
um our next story is some Annunciation
news which I think is very appropriate
here at the toast okay
Brendan Frazier reveals we have all been
pronouncing his name incorrectly
by George we've been pronouncing George
of the Jungle star Brendan Fraser's name
wrong this whole time in a conversation
with Adam Sandler for varieties actors
on actors interview series The 54 year
old Frazier claimed that no one's ever
gotten his name right even though he's
the Talk of the Town right now for his
performance in whale so he says instead
of a similar pronunciation similar to
the 90s sitcom Frasier
Frazier says his name actually rhymes
with razor so it's Fraser
okay that's pretty similar he's a little
dramatic no wonder he's an actor he did
say [ __ ] it he said like I don't care
but like for the record if anyone cares
it's Fraser
I feel like that's reminds me of
Outlander the protagonist her name is
like Claire Fraser
I think
well obviously I wanted to talk about
this because Brendan Fraser is my
boyfriend but also because I've been
hearing Brendan is my boyfriend Brendan
is a god Brendan is a breeze in my hair
on the weekend friend is a relaxing
thought aren't you envious for you it's
not very good I like that
um but mostly I wanted to talk about
this because I've been seeing a lot
about this variety actors on actors
series I don't know if you heard
anything about it it's like a Prime
video series where they're sitting down
like two actors at the same time and
just like having conversations they're
like interviewing one another and here's
the lineup thus far okay it's Kate
Blanchette and Michelle yo Jamie Lee
Curtis and Colin Farrell Laura Dern and
Michelle Williams Viola Davis and
Jennifer Lawrence Carrie Mulligan and
Margot Robbie Brendan Fraser and Adam
Sandler and Joe Alwyn and Paul Mezcal so
everyone's like freaking out over the
Joe Alwyn Paul Mezcal one because
they're both like you know streaming
service book turned TV show hotties
um
and I think it's actually a really good
concept for a show it is but some of
these names it just sounds like a big
circle jerk sorry there's more and they
get better Austin Butler and Janelle
Monae
and these are all people who are
currently on like the Oscars Golden
Globe circuit so they're all promoting
their their most recent project Kate
Hudson and Glenn Powell okay that sounds
good John boyega and Leticia Wright
Anna De armas and Eddie Redmayne and
Paul Dano and Brian Tyree Henry
sorry I forgot like a bunch of them
this doesn't do it for me personally
I've been seeing a lot of Clips on Tick
Tock of like funny moments that have
come out and it does actually look good
I wouldn't watch every single episode I
would just watch the people that like I
care about it's giving CMT Crossroads
let's talk about that yeah agreed when
was the last CMT Crossroads they do them
all the time
the last one I can recall that like I
remember watching like as it was
actively premiering was Zac Brown Band
and Shawn Mendes yeah uh why don't we
just Google it I got my trusty my iPad
was feeling neglected l-o-l I loved that
concept of like pairing country stars
for concerts with pop stars and like
playing each other's music okay oh I
guess they do them a lot but like
they're not all major major right and
some of them are like a bunch of people
so like for king and country just did
one with Breeland Chrissy Metz Natalie
Grant and then yeah
black Pumas and Mickey Guyton Leanne
Rhymes and Carly Paris Ashley McBride
Mickey Guyton and Brandon Clark that's
pretty cool yeah so they call them like
Leanne Rhymes and friends so I guess
when they do like a big like festival
lineup it's with multiple people
still do it I'm glad they're still doing
it I guess not everyone can be like
Casey Musgraves and Katy Perry they do
smaller artists too not everyone can be
like um
and that's sad for everyone yeah that
was a really good one I think that might
be my favorite even though the Shawn
Mendes Zach Brown man is really good
yeah there's also Nick Jonas and Luke
Bryan
there oh there's Halsey and Kelsea
ballerini which are you hearing about
the drama between them no
you know they were like really good
friends
they had a song together graveyard on
Kelsey's last album and then on Kelsey's
new album she has a song that was like
became really good friends with a pop
star even put her on track five
wish I didn't do that if I know if I'd
known we wouldn't be talking I wouldn't
have done it at the time something like
that
it's crazy I know what's the T and her
Crossroads performance of singing You're
just still lost
boy with Halsey went so viral people
were obsessed with the performance I've
seen it probably a hundred times just
like clipped out on Tick Tock people
were obsessed you know who needs to do
one let's pair her up even though would
she be a pop or a country Kelly Clarkson
needs to do a Crossroads oh yeah I feel
like she does Crossroads every day her
life is a crossroad
Luke Combs
okay but would she be the country star
or the puppy uh it reminds me of like
Gavin DeGraw did one and he did one with
Chris Young so it's someone who's like
still more country than him yeah she
needs to do one with like I mean she
could sing anyone's songs I actually saw
a tick tock yesterday that was like I
I'm never gonna become a singer because
I don't want Kelly Clarkson to ever
cover one of my songs better than you
because she'll literally do it better
than you yes she will wait can you think
who would she be a good pair with like
we need to Manifest this into real do
you want a girl or a boy
she's such a girls girl like she needs
to be and she's like almost like a
maternal figure to so many young women
yeah and a mentor so what about that
girl you were just talking about on the
patreon oh Meg Maroney oh my God I would
die I do think they need someone like
slightly more established okay
like Lauren Elena oh that's weird Andres
that would be good too yeah okay just a
thought Crossroads forget some free
ideas
um we have our fourth story now which is
uh we never spoke about how Jay Leno
like literally got burned alive he's
sitting down with Hoda and giving
everyone like an update on what happened
and where he's at he's breaking down the
car fire that sent him to a burn unit
with second and third degree burns and
he's pretty cool when talking about it
comedian sat down for an interview with
Hoda Kotb told her how some mechanical
work on one of his vintage cars turned
ugly in the blink of an eye Jay says
that he was in his Burbank garage last
month working on a white Stream Car
trying to unclog a fuel line he told his
friend to blow some air through the fuel
line when suddenly he was hit in the
face with a full face of gas and it only
got worse from there Jay says his face
caught fire when the car's pilot light
ignited the fuel and he yelled to his
friend I'm on fire fortunately his
friend Dave was Johnny on the spot
pulling him out of Harm's Way jumping on
top of him and smothering the fire and
he's back to business already he's been
pretty casual and recalling the scary
situation
um but he was cracking jokes after the
incident to photographers just 10 days
after so he's okay but he pretty much
was lit on fire that's crazy that's
amazing that his friend was able to save
him though no totally and
um not to make everything about me but
like I did go through something similar
you did not I I was literally engulfed
in flames
you were not
I was in Utah we were on vacation and I
was outside setting um
trying to put the fire outdoor fireplace
on it wasn't what's it called like a
bonfire fire pit pit pit so it's one of
those pits with gas so you basically
just turn the gas on you put the lighter
down and the whole thing engulfs in
Flames but when I leaned down to light
the gas I had two strands of hair
dangling in front of me and the fire
went up on the strands
went all the way up singed off all the
front faces piecing my hair and my
[ __ ] eyelashes like the two scares of
your eyelashes no I would say 50 of my
eyelashes were gone like half of them in
length got singed right off and all my
baby hairs which was kind of nice yeah
so you would say that was engulfed in
flames yeah yeah I would
and I'm just like kind of triggered
reading the story I understand well I'm
happy for Jay Leno um we've been like
seeing his you know recovery and I think
it's great now when he got burned which
thankfully I did not that's the
difference like he actually like left
the hospital with second and third
degree burns I just went inside and I
was like screaming yeah yeah and I
smelled like like I literally into a
cartoon it was like a cartoon I had like
a trail of smoke following me out from
the house and I was like screaming at
Olivia was in the kitchen I'm like help
me You're always screaming now but there
was also nothing she could do like it
was over like the flames never caught
they just burned off all my hair and
then like sit like
fuse out but Olivia was actually pretty
good I was like I couldn't even put into
words I was so [ __ ] shook yeah
that was crazy
I'm just like reliving the trauma you
know I know I'm sorry for you I wouldn't
have chosen that story because I
wouldn't have wanted to bring that up
for you but see the thing about me is
I'm all about healing about confronting
confronting it yeah yeah that you're
you're brave I'm so brave nobody
understands our fifth and final Story
the final story
do do do
it's a final story and it's a little bit
of tech news it's about Instagram
adding text updates with the launch of
notes this should have been the first
story this is
they're adding other share features but
the big thing going on is that a mid
backlash over the intrusion of the
algorithmic recommended content
instrument into Instagram's feed excuse
me Instagram today introduced a number
of new design features that are designed
to make it easier for users to keep up
with their real world Friends real world
friends right the company is now rolling
out several significant changes
including most notably an addition
called notes a feature that meta has
considered turning into a Twitter
competitor according to a recent news
report with notes users can update their
friends using just texted Emoji adding a
different format for social updates
beyond the images and videos Instagram
is best known for other new features are
rolling out to stories and will
introduce new ways to share with groups
so the big feature that everyone's
talking about is notes it's very much
giving like away message yeah I don't
know why it's called notes I don't feel
like I can write a note there I feel
like I can only write like a little five
word thing like rise and cheese sell it
like eBay
yeah hit the cell hit the cell out on
the town right but if you're hitting the
cell why can't I be on Instagram too
right so basically what this means is
like now when you swipe into your
messages like your direct messages
section on Instagram at the very top
people's your mutuals only will if they
if they add an away message it'll be
like in you know like Tahoe for a week
don't text or whatever yeah okay I think
the fact that I was surprised I went to
go do a message leaving like an away
message and I it told me that would only
be people who like I follow them
following the accent oh wait it's
already up yeah oh my God everyone was
freaking oh my God one thing about me is
I'm the last person on the planet oh if
you already had this on your phone you
would have made it the first story
because it's like I don't have it crazy
let me check sometimes the toast
Instagram gets like the new features
first no
no
I can't believe I already have it then
you're so like you have updates in your
app store available
I'm on auto update and anyone who's not
on auto update is [ __ ] psychotic Ben
solver I feel like I'm on auto update
but sometimes it just hasn't updated
maybe I didn't have enough Wi-Fi or
something like yeah maybe you should
check it out no I am always getting the
new updates to Instagram I'm the last
user on the list of people I'm literally
the last of the building that's because
they know you don't like change and it
is for you
I'm so appreciative this is honestly
really stupid like I don't
it is but you know what I'm gonna say
one nice thing because we were just
talking about how social media used to
be more so about connecting with people
that you actually know and I think any
updates that are trying to bring real
world friends closer together I am going
to support like I think one of the best
inventions on Instagram in the last five
years is close friends yeah like I think
it's so funny and I think people
actually feel more inclined to be real
on close friends and actually keep up
with people that they really know or or
want to know or in people who want to
know them and I'm here for updates such
as those that's it that's an interesting
take I agree I think close friends was
like an amazing I don't know why
everyone is comparing this to Twitter it
doesn't feel like Twitter at all they're
just both text yeah and it's like are
people going to be doing indeed are
people going to be doing it every five
minutes
right like tweet tweeting is like very
much a steady stream of thoughts whereas
this feels more like a daily message
yeah yeah
I wonder if I'll use it
I just like I'm now waiting for
Instagram and I know they're gonna take
10 years to do it but like we really
need to start to be able to use two link
stickers on one yep for top link for
pants right like so many influencers
like are well like right now I'm wearing
a set and I linked this set when I wore
it a few days ago and I had to do two
separate stories link for top link for
bottom and if I choose to one
[ __ ] story with two
[ __ ] link stickers that'd be
saving me a lot of trouble I agree and I
think a lot of people even with the
podcast how I'm like tap to listen or
tap to watch like I would love to be
able to link our podcast to YouTube and
to Spotify at the exact same time yep if
anybody with any influence hears this
like please it's such a good idea yeah
no brainer they could probably roll it
out in five minutes if they want in no
but the thing with Instagram is like
they'll say oh a bunch of people want us
to do this okay we'll never do it unless
Tick Tock does it and then it'll be done
tomorrow so [ __ ] true and in this
article they did um mention Instagram
doing this thing called Candid which was
an attempt to rip off be real which Tick
Tock has done too I don't know if you
know this Tick Tock has a another tab
now where it's called moments I think
and it's just to be real
it doesn't come at a certain time
no but you only do it once a day
I kind of like the idea I mean I'm not
gonna be real and I'm not certainly not
on Tick Tock but I kind of like the idea
of getting to do your be real once a day
and you get to choose like what about
your day you want to memorialize but
that's the point it's like you're not
real but like
I think it's okay so it's not about
being real but it's about
memorializing your best life moments and
just one a day we don't need a 100
selfies just actually be real came this
morning so I'm gonna take a smile smile
I love being real I feel like I'm so
real and I just want to show everyone
how real I can be I just want to say
I've actually started to really dislike
be real one I have like no friends on
the platform and I wanted to keep it
just like people I actually know not
just like a public platform so I find
myself incredibly bored by it every
[ __ ] time it comes I'm in my bed and
I'm watching TV and it's like
embarrassing
and like you can go up into your archive
and see like what you've posted every
day nobody else can see it just you and
it's like it's actually embarrassing I'm
literally like in my house all the time
but so maybe that's like I think there's
nothing wrong with that you know I think
no but I have a full life like I'm
always
like right which is why I'm saying like
I actually kind of like the idea of tick
tock moments because you get to
Chronicle like the the best part of your
day and sure it's a highlight reel but
okay sue me since when is that such a
bad thing it's a highlight reel yeah
great totally highlights are cool no I
got dragged to filth on Tick Tock
yesterday
um because I made a tick tock and I was
laying in my bed with no makeup and I
looked so ugly so I put on one of these
filters that like kind of changes your
face but it doesn't add makeup so it
just like made me like a little tan I
guess it made my lips look really big
and like they were dragging me to fail
it's on Tick Tock yeah so you know I
actually have tick tock on my iPad for
work purposes so that I can I do I do
look like a mongrel but it's not my
fault so that I can um
follow our fan accounts yeah oh here
doing my resolutions yeah
okay yeah you look at your Scott filler
and you have a blush but what are they
exciting
they're saying babe these feel this in
my soul
I literally don't see one negative
comment oh uh ready okay that's a a
talent of mine is that I can find
negative comments you know what this is
okay I literally don't see one
okay maybe they deleted them but there
was a bunch
ready
mm-hmm
LMAO this filter is wild Claude holy
lips Batman are you using a filter what
yeah
I don't see it yep
maybe because you're blocking out the
haters with your dip I wear sunglasses
oh my gosh thank you I don't have to
tell you by the way those were my past
five stories how did you think that went
I thought it was really fun to be on the
receiving end of them it's low pressure
it is oh what my thoughts on Jay Leno
sure one of my thoughts on Brendan
Fraser sure
was her Fraser
Fraser and moderna don't don't
disrespect my boyfriend
is my boyfriend
Brazzers god brother she has a breeze in
my hair on the weekend fries are so
relaxed and thought are you envious sad
for you it's not Jackie
Fraser is the thunder rattling the
ground frosters on your scent like a
bounty hunter froster's gonna track you
down step by step from town to town he
really is so good
um are you ready for to your toasters
Our advice segment that we do every
Wednesday where you can write into
deertoesters at gmail.com and get advice
from your favorite girlies and you could
totally submit it anonymously I'm so
ready but not before I tell you a few
things with a message from our sponsors
because today's episode is also brought
to you by fashion pass so you guys if
you've been you know tuning out the ads
for a little bit because Claudia was
reading them they were getting mundane
and you're listening today you need to
know about fashion pass even though I
know so many toasters already know and
love fashion pass it is truly the
steeniest clothing rental service you
get unlimited rentals for one flat price
oh and did we mention their cute ass
clothes
if there was a time to sign up for
fashion pass this is it there are so
many events holidays holiday parties
that you need outfits for and fashion
pass has you covered and if we're being
honest like sometimes you have a holiday
party you have a moment you wear the
outfit ones and then you don't want to
wear it again because everyone will be
like oh that's a dress from holiday
party 2022 which is why fashion pass is
perfect because you wear it once and
then you return it to Fashion pass and
you get something new maybe something
for January maybe something for an
upcoming trip it is such a great way to
shop it's also sustainable takes up less
space in your closet and it's commitment
free some people I know not me but other
people are like very commitment averse
and honestly buying clothes is a big
commitment but not with fashion pass you
obviously want to look sickening
everywhere you go but that gets
expensive when you want a new outfit for
every event but sometimes you get an
outfit for an event and you're like oh
this dress looks so amazing on me like
I'm gonna wear it 500 more times and
it's going to become everyone else's
problem and fashion pass is great for
that too because you can buy it off of
fashion pass you can get something and
you can decide I don't want to send it
back I want to keep it for myself so you
can buy it from Fashion pass at a better
price than retail they really think of
ever everything they offer free shipping
and returns it's super easy you can
purchase brand new items or buy like new
items for huge discounts up to 70 off
which is amazing
so we actually have a special discount
code for you today it's their biggest
discount ever are you listening is
everyone listening go to fashionpass.com
and use code toast at checkout you'll
get 50 off your first month so you can
try it literally for thirty nine dollars
that's unlimited rentals for just 39 a
month with code toast that is an amazing
price for a closet full of clothes it's
worth trying no fashionpass.com code
toast now before we get into Deer
toasters I absolutely must tell you this
episode is sponsored by betterhelp so
we've been talking about betterhelp on
the show for years now but I do feel
like there are different seasons of your
life and also seasons of the Year where
betterhelp is a resource that you might
need more than other times I personally
feel like the holidays though they can
be so joyous they can also bring on
feelings of loneliness maybe isolation
and sadness depending on you know
previous memories that you might have
experienced there's a million different
reasons why you might be feeling down
this holiday season and better help is
here for you just like they are always
here for you unfortunately life does not
come with a user manual so when it's not
working for you it's normal to feel
stuck and navigating any of life's
changes can make you feel unsure whether
it's a career change a new relationship
becoming a parent therapists that better
help are trained to help you figure out
the cause of challenging emotions and
learn productive coping skills which
makes therapy the closest thing to a
guided tour of the complex engine called
you that is such straight facts you are
a complex engine and you know what
sometimes you need a little tuning up
and that's what betterhelp is here for
it is the world's largest therapy
service they have matched 3 million
people with professionally licensed
embedded vetted therapists available 100
online plus it is Affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime couldn't be simpler no waiting
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapist learn more and
save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com toast that's better help
help.com toast check it out
okay I'm excited for deer toasters
because usually I read them and I've
read them prior so now I'm getting like
a blind reaction to people's problems I
have not read these prior either so we
can both oh I see the words period blood
okay yes let's Jump Right In to Deer
toasters which is our weekly advice
segment where you can write into us
we'll give you the best advice based on
our personal experience and things that
we feel and that we know and that we
think would be the best remedy for you
it's just you know it's personal
honestly advice is more personal than
comedy add it to the list you know I
would except I don't know if you've
noticed I can't find my phone I've been
looking for it all episodes I keep
hearing it vibrate somewhere is that
torture usually before the episode I
turn it on do not disturb but I couldn't
find it before the episode so I didn't
and now I'm just hearing like these
vibrations are driving me crazy so
unfortunately okay the list will suffer
I hate to see it first up dear Jackson
Claude love you girlies and all that
yada yada so here's the sich I live with
two of my best friends and we all share
a bathroom whenever one of the girls
goes to the bathroom she somehow always
leaves something behind on the toilet
some days it's a couple pubes others
it's period blood it's not massive
amounts but enough to gross a girl out
I've texted in our group chopper for us
to not single her out and it still
happens almost every time she leaves the
bathroom I'm currently writing this
after seeing some sort of
discharge on the seat I'm now sitting on
my question is how do I bring it up do I
bring it up all or just deal with it do
I bring it up at all or just deal with
it yes you [ __ ] bring it up oh my God
disgusting she's one of my best friends
but we haven't even been friends for a
full year yet so things are still a
little touchy yesterday I had to ask her
not to slam the doors in the morning as
it's right next to my room and wakes me
up she handled it well and we joked
about it but you could tell it bothered
her I don't want to be nitpicky this
isn't it picky because I'm sure there's
annoying things I do too sure let her
tell you but I like for there to be open
communication I don't want to embarrass
her but I like to like I deserve to sit
on a blood-free toilet seat right thanks
for any help smooches okay by the way
the door thing is like actually so
different because I feel like you would
like in the morning close your door not
realize like the walls are thin like
being told that like I feel if she's
offended by that like seriously [ __ ] her
and honestly like this one literally
pissed me off of course you say
something and you know what I'm really
tired of having to like dance around
other people's sensitivities like you
left your [ __ ] discharge on the
toilet seat like you have and I have a
problem this is so nasty and and also
unhygienic unsanitary like to have just
like blood laying around where other
people like put their openings like it's
just right not clean whatsoever like the
lack of self-awareness like if I
sometimes I like will be in a public
setting I'll use the bathroom like I'll
pee and then I will have like paranoia
that I didn't flush
that's one thing and this is like all
the time there's something being left
behind like no pube left behind this is
horrible no and I feel like this is
really like symptomatic of the culture
we live in where like people are afraid
to confront other people and also you
don't want to offend her people are
unashamed oh well that's another we need
to bring back shame I agree we need to
shame everyone into submission no like a
little shame is a good thing like you
shouldn't feel shame like unnecessarily
but like shame will have you acting
right
no because I feel I feel like you know a
couple of years ago especially like
online there was this movement to like
normalize periods and talk about it like
we shouldn't have to hide it you don't
have to put your tampon up your sleeve
when you go to work to go change your
tampon and like while I do approve the
message I actually think [ __ ] like this
is a direct result of that movement and
why maybe things got so constricted in
the first place it's like okay right if
we talk about period blood will that
lead to girls leaving it on the seat we
can't talk about it then right right no
I I'm like Angry on your behalf
definitely say something like maybe not
like this is gross like maybe start
documenting it
yeah I would take some pictures and send
them in the group chat like I would
escalate the situation until she can't
ignore it so first you said something
like and you were like tiptoeing around
the situation I would take a pic and say
hey who wants to come clean this up
who's on their period like start being
an investigator and then like once if
she doesn't claim it then be like I it's
you hey hey yeah I spoke to her we know
it's you I don't even know you girl and
like if you don't start cleaning up
after yourself like this is so
unhygienic like you're gonna have to
move out I could not live with someone
like this like no because that's the
thing it's your house too and your home
should be a beacon of Peace for you and
you have war in your home and there's
that's not okay like [ __ ] with with
someone's personal space like that's not
okay no people are so irrationally angry
about this I'm so angry it's not okay
take your take matters into your own
hands and you're not even like so close
with this girl but honestly even if I
had a friend that I was like so close to
it and they did stuff like this like I
don't think we could be that close
honestly yeah because it speaks to a
larger lack of self-awareness and like I
can't be friends and the lack of
consideration who just like doesn't care
for people doesn't see themselves like
just goes through life like leaving
pubes and not and not like feeling
self-conscious no and you know what
roommates are tough and they're an
interesting Dynamic and if somebody's
really messy and they want to keep their
personal space messy like you know what
that is their personal choice but the
communal space is especially a bathroom
you need to have a level of respect and
if you don't like I think you're a bad
friend I do yeah oh for sure and I just
hate people who are like oh man I'm like
so busy like couldn't bother to flush
like that's not a thing what I'm pretty
sure Beyonce flushes I'm pretty sure her
majesty hrh the queen flushes no that's
so trashed flushed
unacceptable
I'm pretty sure Elon Musk flashes
actually I'm pretty sure he has auto
flush
SoJO which is problematic for a whole
other list but the thing is this isn't
even about flushing this is about
leaving you know a little your extra
party favor on the toilet seat stop are
you ready for our next story yeah
hi girly pops my college roommate let's
call her Lucy help me snag an awesome
job and her mother-in-law is now my boss
okay Lucy's a pretty mother of the
college friend is married
so true maybe it's her siblings
you know what I mean like oh like when
someone's parents be called my
mother-in-law no okay good to know or
maybe they were friends in college yes
yes yes my college roommate from however
many years ago okay okay Lucy helped me
snag an awesome job in her mother-in-law
is not my boss Lucy is a pretty private
person and despite her and I being close
she likes to share about her personal
life on her own time
her mother-in-law however likes to spill
the beans on to Lucy's life to anyone
that will listen a few weeks ago at a
work meeting she shared to the group of
about 10 people that she was having a
hard day because Lucy had a miscarriage
something that I as Lucy's best friend
hadn't even known yet I let it go
thinking maybe it was a lapse in
judgment due to grief until this week
she also shared to another large group
that Lucy's brother was getting a
divorce I know Lucy would not be chilled
with so many people knowing these
intimate details but I also know my boss
is a really kind and great person who
just has a big mouth what do I do do I
tell Lucy her mother-in-law's filling
the beans and tattletail my boss or do I
continue to find out about my friend's
life through her blabbermount boss
toastly a wenchy worker
see that's tough because if you snitch
like you're snitching on your boss and
there's no way that like the boss
wouldn't figure out that it was you who
snitched once our kids start getting mad
at her and also like if you didn't have
this job like the Mother-in-law could go
about her life like telling her friends
and her co-workers like about things
that are going on in her life and like
Lucy would never know so I kind of think
you have to keep the two things separate
I don't think it does we'll see any
service to find out I think it's not
going to change anything except drive a
wedge between Lucy and her mother-in-law
like I don't think that you need to tell
her
I was gonna say like you should tell
Lucy just not but be like Lucy like you
can't say anything but I just want you
to know that like your mother-in-law has
the biggest mouth so just be cautious of
what you share with her if you don't if
it's something you don't want getting
out maybe be very vague just be like
she's you know always like at you know
big meetings sharing things about her
family and like if there was something
you told her that you didn't want to get
out like I would hate for you to confine
her confide in her and be betrayed
in the middle of this person's family
yeah you know what I mean like it's
it's just like sharing that Lucy had a
miscarriage no I know it's it's not good
it's really bad
but I don't think you inserting yourself
into in-law drama is a solution
yeah no you're so right about that and
like sometimes it's true you gotta keep
your work stuff at your work stuff and
your personal life and your personal
life and like the only thing that I
think is a shame is like now you know
that that Lucy had a miscarriage and
like you can't even reach out and be
like are you okay I'm here for you
without giving it off either way yeah
oh this is a real pickle yeah I would
like I kind of want you to be able to be
like I heard like I you know
I heard from
or like whatever that you are going
through like a tough time like I just
want to be here for you and that might
signal to Lucy like oh yes if that like
was a problem for her that her
mother-in-law was filling the beans
um that's a good idea because then you
can reach out and comfort your friend
while also subliminally being like yeah
your mom told me mother-in-law yeah yeah
that's a good answer it's a compromise
because yeah I don't know but then it's
like if you didn't tell someone
something so personal and then they came
to you and they knew about it because
they want to offer their condolences
like if I wanted your condolences I
would have told you so it's like you are
kind of being selfish and like reaching
out because you feel like you want to be
there as a friend
I I honestly don't know
no I think it's okay
she said like it's not that Lucy didn't
want to share with her Lucy's very close
it off and maybe she'll just like be
relieved that she didn't have to tell a
person that this person already knows
and she can like confide in her friend
I don't know it's like if I wanted you
there for me I would have told you I
actually think that is probably the best
way to go about doing it because
then Lucy will know her mother-in-law
shared it
while also now being able to talk about
it with her friend like she said they're
best friends
and she's just not like a really open
person
I think that you should be like I heard
from your mother-in-law are you okay
then you're spilling the beans without
like being like a gossip about it if you
feel compelled to do something that
would be the right course of action yes
okay that's a good response considering
all of the Dynamics if it were me
I don't think I would do anything yeah I
would just pretend like I was in the
bathroom when she said that I don't know
anything
yeah don't look at me I don't know I
don't know what thing totally okay are
you ready for our last one yes dear
Jackie and Claudia last year my brother
will call him William married a girl
named Kate William and Kate moved into
my parents basement after getting
married I am his younger sister and live
there too Kate and I became close
sister-in-laws but one night we were
drinking wine and she spilled a secret
she told me before she met my brother
she was engaged to a girl she said they
lived together and she broke off the
engagement just months before meeting my
brother she proceeded to tell me not to
tell him or anyone my brother is
completely in the dark about her past
what the [ __ ] do I do do I tell him
confront her about it again love a
sister-in-law who is confused yeah I
don't think it's a big deal
they're already married so what's gonna
happen yeah and like you know everyone
has a past
it's not like she was you know her
pastor she was on the run like she was a
little gay I would say it depends on
your closeness with your sibling like
yeah I would [ __ ] tell my sisters
well for sure but like we are the mafia
right but like are you guys the mafia
like do you are you I don't know but
like my advice I would tell me if I can
sibling anything I know about your
partner yeah but like brothers and
sister relationships are different like
they really are okay still a sibling
still your blood it doesn't matter what
she was like even she was engaged period
before like I would tell you right and
sibling I would tell them anything
yeah like I don't come to like the the
spouse you know don't come to me as a
safe place for your secrets because it's
all going right back to him do you think
she's hiding it because he doesn't want
her to know that she was engaged or she
doesn't want him to know that she was
engaged to a woman
both hmm
I don't think it will change anything
but I do think that like
Partners now that I think about it sorry
it's kind of like a crazy thing to keep
from your husband yeah engaged yeah
yeah I'll have a pass okay yeah we all
have a pass but like you share your
story with your partner it's not like
you just meet someone and from that day
forward that that really that's all that
matters truly But like everyone that has
a history and in order to know you I
need to know your history like in order
to understand you yeah
tell your freaking brother
yeah tell your brother if you're close
or like sometimes you know you're not
that close but like this is the sister
you never had like decide like whose
side do you want to take for life or
also you could just like be sneaky and
you all get drunk on mine and you're
like you're drunk and you're like and
you let it slip like it's like you let
it slip you're like where is she now and
your brother's like who no I love that
idea you're just like the crazy drunk
younger sister
the crazy drunk younger sister she gets
in no trouble Jackie the crazy drunk
younger sister works every time
well those with your dear twisters and I
hope that we made meaningful impact
today I really do I do too so do you
enjoy the swap I very much did I'm
curious if the toasters did did you yeah
I really did like I love reading for our
sponsors and letting everyone know what
great brands that we work with and how
they don't impact your life for the
better I do have some notes for you but
we will share them afterwards as I'm
sure you have notes for me no I really
don't what are your notes tell me
it's business stuff it's business stuff
a little long I I hit all the call to
actions thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so at Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio I got ready to castbox all
the places of every listen to podcast
find us the toes leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
talented we are have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow bye